une nouvelle yvelinoise entre
gouvernement Aurore Bergé nommé ce jeudi
20 juillet ministre des Solidarités par
Emmanuel Macron est député en marge de
la dixième circonscription des Yvelines
elle est élue en 2017 avec 64% face à
Jean-Frédéric Poisson elle est confirmée
par un deuxième mandat en 2022 avec 63%
des suffrages elle est depuis président
du groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée
nationale élu le 22 juin 2022 Aurore
berger est aussi conseillère régional
depuis le scrutin de juin 2021
son entrée dans la vie politique elle
l'a fait en 2014 en tant que conseiller
municipal de position à
Magny-les-Hameaux est conseillère
communautaire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines initialement
cartés chez les républicains elle
rejoint le mouvement en marche en 2017
Aurore berger nommé ministre à la place
de Jean-Christophe combe elle rejoint un
autre rive du nom au gouvernement
Jean-Noël Barrault ministre de la
transition numérique et des
télécommunications